this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday
march the 28th from the heart of jersey
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings the best
join the action on the court during the
biggest college basketball tournament of
the year this weekend with draftkings i
know you guys been watching we're down
to the [__] elite eight we got saint
peter's prep we got arkansas it's over
let me tell you what draftkings is doing
new customers but finals only college
team to win and get 200 in free bets if
they do to plop on the [__] final
four and then for the monday night
championship now if sportsbook isn't
available in your state yet there's no
problem you can still join the college
groups action with draftkingspool
everyone i mean everybody plays for free
free pools the whole month of march for
a long shot had a share of over 250
thousand dollars in prizes are you
kidding me or what do yourself a favor
download the draftking sports book app
now use promo code joey j o e y bet 5
money college hoop team to win and get 2
miles and free bets if they do if they
win you win with promo code joey this
week at draftking sportsbook 21 over
restrictions apply don't let that hinder
the [__] situation you're getting
paid this [__] weekend we got pro
basketball we got college basketball and
oh [__]
baseball's around the corner
so download the draftking sportbook app
now use promo code
joey the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen if you run a small
business the time and effort you put
into it is anything but small time is
money print official postage right from
your computer and save yourself time and
a ton of money with stamps.com you spend
less time at the post office and more
time making your customers happy we've
been working with stamps.com for about
12 years now my wife loves it she weighs
the packages she puts the arrow up on
the post thing on the mailbox the
mailman picks up the packages it's that
simple stamps.com even gives you access
to all the post office and ups shipping
services you need with discounts you can
find anywhere else all you need is a
computer and a standard printer no
special supplies or equipment get
started in minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want to send
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com i don't care whether you got
a small business big business i don't
care if you're sending pictures of my
head out sign up with promo code joey
j-o-e-y for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial and free
postage and digital scale
no long-term commitment to contracts go
to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter code joey now without
further ado let's get this party started
i got lee and steve simone in the house
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joint monday the
28th of beautiful march today we have
the [__]
the team of decked here we got the
catholic steve simone
and we got the jew on the other side
lisa for a fun-filled uncle joey's joint
the bong is here for [__] decoration
we can't smoke my daughter's upstairs
doing math homework
you know how that goes now she's not
even home thank god we're all here but
thank god for [__] uh abx and the
filters of death i got a couple
different companies i got abx with these
little [__] vaper pens there it goes
maybe not who knows
there you go
we're starting this monday morning with
a [__] bangkok suckers lisa how's it
going how do you like jersey my friend i
love it i don't know how you're not 800
pounds i'm i told you [__] when
it comes to food my neighborhood is the
[__] you think i moved here to be a
[__] x-ray you know what i'm saying i
moved here because of the [__] food
not that i always want to eat but just
knowing that it's there yep that's what
we didn't have in that other [__]
hell hole where we live no
we miss la you know i miss la i miss
some of my good friends
some of the food was good we were
talking about lalas last night yeah
but beside that nothing is like what i'm
i should be
about 516 pounds right now
yeah if i'm on the 10 pound a week game
but [__] it i just uh
i had to put the discipline on man
because i could eat the killer is two
slices a day
that means i would be at 14 slices a
week
that i can't recover from a [__] 60.
but two slices a week
i could recover from a couple push-ups
two or three little walks and i'm okay
you know what i'm saying but it's so
quick like we went to get pizza today
for lunch steve and i and i thought
i just forgot that you could go places
and get a slice i thought we were gonna
sit down and they were gonna bring out a
pie like i didn't i've never you can't
sit down and eat pizza if you can get a
slice in five minutes here i would stop
more i would get more than 14 a week
back then i would've when i left 1083 i
was eating 14 slices a week
metabolism was different there was
cocaine there was a lot of things
happening you know what i'm saying now i
can't do those 14 slices a week but i
hope you guys
understood when i said to you when we go
to that pizza parlor on selma or we go
to the pizza parlor joe's in l.a how
everything was a pro like they didn't do
a slice
when you're advertising a slice you're
not advertising a slice you're
advertising that i'm gonna be in and out
of your place in two [__] minutes
that's what a slice is a slice is
something on the move yeah you go to
pizza with your kids and your
grandparents and you sit around and talk
about the pepperoni that's one thing
i'm talking about when you [__] go
with you know you're working you're
working you have a 15-minute break yeah
you got a 15-minute break it's two
o'clock i ate my pizzas at two o'clock
let's be honest there's nothing better
than a slice at two in the afternoon
lunch is already settled
you [__] the fruit out you know what i'm
saying the beer you had is gone now
you're looking for something to keep you
together till 6 6 30. what better thing
a little slice a little diet coke
and then after you eat the slice you
know what
i'll take another one [__] it out i'll
you know
because slices are by the day sometimes
i go i went to [__] carlos the other
day and i got there the guy goes you
want to slice or you want to wait two
minutes for a sausage to come out
and i said you know what i'll wait two
minutes for the sauce to come out i
walked in there thinking i was gonna get
a cheese i had the flavor of cheese in
my mouth you understand me but i ended
up getting the sausages because that's
the way it goes today i went there to
get one slice
sometimes you get two i was gonna say i
thought you were gonna get a cheese
while you waited for the sausage
but that yours the one we went to you
told us to go to is across the street
from a carvel i got a black and white
milkshake
black and whites are my favorite gong
gum it's it's vanilla ice cream and
chocolate sauce instead of just
chocolate ice cream as a milkshake
it just brought like
to be able to walk from pizza
to carvel and it's next to a deli oh
the place where i got you the sandwich
before we had the pizza yeah oh yeah we
didn't have a valve yeah no it
it's heaven it's food heaven it's the
absolute best and then you
like i knew like you met us at dinner
last night
and you were the our waiter didn't say
two words to us
you walk in everyone's heart like you
ever like
everyone just loves you here that's my
spot
that's my chinese place there's a guy i
went to i went to chinese place with a
friend of mine there there the cop
and he started with his [__] you
know uh this is a great place but i
think you should go to the other place
down the road then i'm like you don't
understand
i don't do that
once i find my place
unless the other place the chicks had
firecrackers coming out of a [__]
i'm loyal to my people yeah you know
everybody always says this that about
restaurants if your lawyer how loyal are
you as a [__] customer for that
restaurant yeah can they count on your
business every week or do you alternate
do you tell people about that business
so
these places that i've kind of
accustomed to we're talking about empire
szechuan that's my spot they laugh at me
like they make fun of me when i go in
there i love that when chinese people
make fun of you at a restaurant
she'll call my wife and go your husband
here with blonde
you know she'll do [__] like that to me
like they do all that type of [__]
with their family well who who has like
a friend at the like who's friends with
their chinese restaurant people and you
like it's a good thing are you doing
yeah
i've never had that like they're like
they're your friends they're my friends
my buddy vince the tomato pie i brought
you he doesn't open he's open 15 days a
year
and every time i come into philly he's
like all right how many pies do you need
he'll open up the business just for me
for money the rest of the year he's got
like a property business he's like in
the construction these [__] pizzas
oh my god with just a pie with salt we
got a slice tomato pie a tomato [__]
pie it's ridiculous
obviously you [__] here at this
show today is about food yeah listen
tell
[__] guy fieri to suck your dick and
tell [__] that other [__]
that
bobby flay that ignorant [__] sucker but
he always wins nobody beats bobby flay
nobody beats bobby flay i know like
there was a white chick on there last
week that'll [__] bobby flay up but they
always give it to bobby flay it's a fix
bobby play [__] you the [__] food
network i was thinking of taking
something over to you [__] but
you always let bobby wood and then even
my wife stopped watching it she goes i'm
watching this that the these people are
obviously beating bobby flay as they're
tasting it the judge is like this is the
best bro
and then bobby comes along and [__]
wins
[__] bobby play that funk ass [__]
yeah that guy with the glasses and [__]
yeah this it's a goofy [__] network
they got ugly people on there bobby
blay's to wake up and his twitter's
going to be messed up
and then they always [__] get up and
they always they always torture like the
people he's [__] going up against to
throw them off
then they believe they do it to bobby
flayer like oh let's torture bobby a
little bit they cheer against bobby
did you see the leo on that one
that must have been pre before the 18
year old raise the hand and [__] before
the bus girl said something
the lea is alive and kicking now they're
doing great yeah they're doing good so
happy for all those [__] idiots that
came out against dalia and
brian callan they opened up a can of
worms that they didn't know they were
gonna open up obviously they didn't
think about what they were gonna [__]
say or whatever now they realize why
people shut the [__] up because if you
say something they're gonna bring you in
it's like i was watching the sopranos
that guy that was a witness and he told
the cops i'm a good citizen i should
have said something then two weeks later
his name is in the paper and he's like
i'm gonna get killed by the gangsters
that's why i shut your [__] find your
business set your [__] mouth sometime
you want to be a [__] playboy or a
boy scout do it on your own [__] time
go tie a shoelace
go bring a donut to a homeless guy what
the [__] is wrong with you but they're
doing great and i don't you know what
i'm happy for him a lot of people turn
that back on him he got to see
where he stood in life
and once you see where you stand in life
you're [__] brand new you're brand
new he's got nothing to talk about
nobody to talk with [__] you you said
[__] about me on twitter yeah and he
moves on i check him with delete all the
time
i love chris he loves being a dad he's a
family his parents are awesome like i
love that come on man these what
happened was he was [__] people when
he was being a dick
you're not going to chick sucks your
dick you're like oh you're finished get
the [__] out of here you can't do that
for these chicks these chicks actually
think that they want to get married to
you or something
so it was just a bad situation i'm happy
we all moved down from that
i'm happy all the stupid [__]
that people were saying [__]
everybody moved on from it and now you
see
now you see why we're the way we are now
now what do you got now you got
comedians that aren't to [__] talk to
you yeah that's what you got now
comedians that aren't going to [__]
talk to they're scared i know a comic no
names he said he will never do another
meet and greet he doesn't give a
frenchman's [__] yeah because god forbid
you touch somebody wrong whatever so
that that's what you get now that's what
you get you want to complain about
comedians you know that's why dog and
there was
still some creepy [__] i got
i took a picture with a [__] i told
you about that three years ago i went to
like toledo
i went to toledo ohio was that would you
tell them
okay yeah the funny bonus
yep
about four [__] years ago five
[__] years ago
in between a dog it was so long i don't
[__] remember
i took a picture with a [__]
i was in the hot lobby in the hotel
like about five or no no on a saturday
especially in a small town because
everybody knows you're at that hotel
yeah i went out for dinner but it was a
smaller hotel didn't have room service
usually for dinner at any hotel on
saturday i just have room service
because you don't really want to go out
i do all my [__] early i go to the gym
and then i go up to the room about four
watch tv for a little while
and then i didn't do that that day i
went out when i came back they were
checking in
now she was really attractive and so was
he they were a young couple they were
like 32. yeah she took a picture of me
he took a picture of me then they both
took a picture of me
never thought about it again
hi goodbye they said i was very
approachable whatever two years later
i'm getting a [__] email
looking for my address
he was filing for divorce and he used
one of my pictures with the chick to say
she was cheating on him huh
that's terrible i'm saying so now i got
an answer to an attorney and all of you
know
yeah the attorney might hit me up
well you have
oh my god
so with all that [__] now how do you
feel after that do you want to
you know how do you want my behavior to
be after that
you know ufc fighters are taking
pictures with people they would say get
me in a headlock and a year later
they're getting sued because they said
when you got them in a headlock you hurt
their [__] neck
and it sucks because like the vast
majority like
95 percent of people we meet or i've met
through this have been so cool
but the crazy have gotten crazier
and it's just
it's not it like it's just not worth it
like as much as it would suck to be like
i can't take a picture but it's like is
this the one time i take a picture and
someone says i did something or even
yesterday some guys first time in six
months anyone said anything to me about
the church
some guys stopped me at a gas station
but they literally pulled over they
weren't even really in the spot they
left the car running and i was like am i
about to get [__] like
like
something yeah
like i'm nowhere in the middle of
nowhere in connecticut
but it's all like you think about it now
i get it and mine
is
a hundredth a thousandth of what you're
like
i said last night as a joke to like how
often do you get recognized because it
happened last night when we were out and
your wife was like oh every day
like that
that's a little bit much that that must
get a little bit old no you say hello to
people there's some people who are last
night i was in the restaurant friday i
went to a restaurant in cold snack
and
i thought i got 12 kids
and i got 12 adults
you know i got like six sets of parents
and we're sitting we just come from
attack a flag football game
and we're sitting there we're having a
good time with the kids and all of a
sudden a guy comes in with kids
and they stop because the waitress is
there and i make eye contact with the
guy
and he looks at me like what's happening
he goes how you doing man he goes i love
you in the longest shot he shook my hand
and he kept moving with his kids great
people yeah that's it he goes that's
mercy i go yeah i listen to the podcast
he walked away yeah
there's some other kid i was going to
say good people make it easy to be nice
but people make it easy they make it
easy they make life easy but then
there's problem people where are you
going then i got two kids around me i
got the my daughter's sitting on me and
i got the neighbor girl busting my balls
because my pants were short and they
could see my ass cracked so the neighbor
girl kept saying i'm going to throw
pennies in there mr diaz
and listen some kid goes are you joe
diaz and i'm like
no you got the wrong guy just because i
knew
what he wanted when you see a guy with
two kids he was he was excited you know
he was very excited he was young and i
knew he was gonna hang there he might
even slip and say where's the reefer at
or something right i'm sitting next to a
cop
detective
you know he knows i get high but i don't
want to slam it in his face right so i
go nah nah and he goes everybody [__] it
you look just like him anybody ever tell
you that and the detective goes i tell
him all the time but he looks just like
joe diaz he won't listen and everybody's
laughing at the table and the guy's like
man you look just like joey i didn't do
that because i was a scumbag i did it
because i know that
what it was gonna open the other guy had
kids with them and yeah
nice you know whatever polite i love
talking to people i love listen i'm a
chatty you know what i'm saying like i
love talking to people if you're cool
with me
and you approach me the right way i'll
talk to you for 10 [__] years the
other day i went to loboties ended up
talking to some guy out there for
[__] 20 minutes about
uh cgi yep you know he just he came up
to me he's like i'm in high school and i
want to learn he goes when they shot in
the sopranos that they really and we
talked yeah he didn't want to take a
picture he didn't give a [__] about
comedy
polite polite and respectful respectful
that like i remember being in a bar i
wasn't even drinking but i was like five
years ago or whatever bartender slammed
and uh you know i catch though and i
said excuse me i could say that you're
busy but when you have a chance may
please
get a diet coke with no ice and the guy
goes what i said i understand you're
busy
but when you please just a diet coke
anyone you know what whatever you want
it's free i go what he goes
order whatever you want he goes you're
the only polite person we've had in here
in a year use whatever you want i got it
like because people don't do that
anymore there's no more common courtesy
i think that over the
with the situation the last two years i
think
you know man i i call it like a mental
health issue because maybe i had a
little bit of a mental health issue
but at times when you see all these
planes and stuff i i was thinking about
the planes that it was
people have been in the house too long
and they forgot how to act
that was just a stupid excuse i know
that the planes you know when i did the
plane to austin
just the amount of times the [__]
lady told me to put the mask on even
though i had my mask on
you know she can't put it on they had
like a recording yeah i wanted to get up
and punch myself in the [__] face
right never mind punched like the
stewardess or i didn't want to punch
none of them in the face i wanted to
punch myself in the [__] face because
it was so [__] annoying yes you know
right now people for a long time people
didn't know where their money was coming
from yes you know we were talking about
la before these people were paying two
month two thousand dollars a month rent
they didn't pay rent for a year and a
half you owe your landlord forty [__]
g's yeah that's a lot of money you know
forty [__] cheese you're never gonna
get out of that trust me i was down 100
g's that's ten [__] years yeah that's
you're down 100 g's that's [__]
forget it 10 years with all your
[__] because you got to remember you
have
rent did anybody say i think steve
harvey was paying the government
450 000 a month did you see that wasn't
it because like his accountant sold like
20 million dollars from him his
accountant stole him he was filing taxes
and didn't file the taxes oh my goodness
and then he died and then like yeah you
owe us 20 years back taxes or what no
not 20 years i don't know how long it
was a long [__] time for you to owe
450 000 a month that's a lot of money
and he goes i paid that for how long no
wonder he has that judge show now no
that's what he said he goes i did
everything i didn't turn down anything i
was not a position to turn down anything
he goes i just worked and he goes i
bumped into a contract that was
big and that paid the bulk of it off
but
450 000 a month
and still pay for your car payment
because that [__] don't stop yeah life
doesn't stop groceries and they don't
have a toyota which is still expensive
we had someone come on the podcast once
who
was
very nice but like not a known person
and they came in and they was talking
about like a 2100 one bedroom with a 900
a month mercedes lease
and it i was like what are you talking
about and they were there for like they
were they were new to l.a
a 900 a month car my buddy wally was in
la for a month and like you know you
meet idiots when you're first there in
like an acting class whatever the guy
was living in a studio apartment and he
was driving a ferrari
he was leasing a ferrari and living in a
studio apartment parking it on the
street oh that's l.a
gross yeah living above their
people buddy no idea that every did you
anybody watching la lakers show
on hbo hbo max
pretty [__] good show the making of
the lakers i'm gonna tell you something
i like thomas c riley mm-hmm that's his
name he was a boogie john's john cena
johnny riley he's always to me been a
good actor me too i met him once i
didn't really say anything to him hi
nice to meet you but let me tell you
something bro he's always been like a
mediocre actor in my world even though
people put him on a pedestal for years
when you see him playing jerry buss
dr buss is it great that show's great me
and my wife watching
religiously at 901 that's awesome but
what was i going to get there we were
talking about we're talking about l.a we
were talking about people's bills all
the sadness people are carrying with
them and just be nice like you were
talking about the people approaching you
yeah people kills and all the stress
people are under and i realize that now
like go out of your way just to be a
little bit nicer to people you know what
i mean because people
i will say one thing i love about jersey
philly this east coast when you're nice
to people
they immediately give it back to you
like they're so grateful like the guys
in the pizza place they were so like
excuse me said please and excuse me and
the guy kept on checking in on us how do
you like it he gave us
the bigger size orangini balls than what
we paid for like
they take care of you you know what i
mean like you put good out there you get
good back but then like at a certain
point like i did a lot of uh podcasts
for real estate agents in la and beverly
hills i did two different ones and i
would go and record sometimes at like
these really beautiful houses
but like the houses in beverly hills
didn't really i never felt comfortable
in them they never feel like a home at
all and like it was
the numbers would blow you away like a
two million dollar house for them was
like a starter house yeah all houses
were like 10 million 12 million it's
like if i could live in a
six hundred thousand dollar house and
not have to work versus
have to do uh
a show i might not want to do but live
in a 12 million dollar house it's like
maybe you should just live in a regular
house and retire yes do whatever you
want
less stress like why do you have this
like 12 bedroom estate i don't know i
never liked
if you know anything about me i love
doing stand-up and i love working doing
movies i never liked
the attention people in that field get
yeah you know meanwhile [__] surgeons
are saving lives yes and nobody talks to
them nobody wants to take a picture with
them yeah nobody wants to do nothing
nobody has a picture of them for
baseball nothing yeah you know and all
that's great
i never liked that
if you know anything about me i never
liked
the [__] somebody bringing me water
right that that just wasn't for me
so when i left when i left la
it was an easy unwind for a guy like me
me too i wasn't tied up with a publicist
i wasn't going to premieres
i did not and now i feel like
like you know we're talking about the uh
comedy store 50th anniversary which is
on april 7.
comedy store is a big part of my life i
wouldn't have a wife if it wasn't for
star kid
a career nothing i mean
and it's really painful for me to think
about going there like i'm like
do i want to i'm not in that world
anymore that's not my world no more you
know i yeah you're so much happier that
was because we've talked yeah over the
past year and a half but like seeing you
like when you came up with mercy and
terry last night
it's just like how happy like i told
steve say i was like i'm so happy that
you're so happy yeah yeah like it's like
it's just noticeable it was time to get
out of that guy for me it was
i like being a stand-up comic me too i
liked everything that came with it but
somewhere along the line
it went south for a guy like me
it just went south i wasn't enjoying
what i was doing anymore i can't believe
that i sacrificed this part of my life
to be a stand-up and all of a sudden i
didn't want to do it anymore it was very
hard for me to
i think to comprehend and process it and
i struggle a lot with it but it's you
know i kept telling people last year uh
by next july i'll be on stage you know
by next april
this whatever i'm going through no
i pulled away from it even more
like i pulled away from it even more
i'm enjoying watching movies again just
for a movie yeah not to look at it to
see who the actor is right
i always knew
that when i did the sopranos i always
had a funny feeling that was gonna be my
last movie
like i always just had a funny feeling
like i did we crashed and
whatever else i did something for greg
garcia and stuff but i don't
i don't know i just
this was a perfect way to unwind for me
like i needed this you know i'm happy
that lee's doing
and looks like a [__] star thank you
i mean when i pulled up at the chinese
restaurant
and i could see him from behind i was
like wow look at [__] lee
you know for people who don't know you
know we were talking about it before i
mean there was a day i went looking for
these two [__] humps
and i'm driving up magnolia and i make a
left onto [__] kawenga whatever that
was tonga a nice kahunga and i see lee i
see simone walking like you know johnny
you know tip top magoo nowhere he's
taking a stroll here and i go what the
[__] is lee and elise looks like
[__] the guy from you know what's the
guy that rings bells
his whole left side was stuck he looked
like the guy in splash when he shot
himself with the nova plane
what's that dude and and whatever was
ripping him out of there tom axel he's
like hold on
it was hot i was 300 something pounds i
was so concerned we would have you all
yeah joey and i would talk
and like i was so concerned and then
when i started to see the weight come
off but to see it in person
i'm so proud of you i'm happy for you it
was happy yeah happy for you
yeah it just i don't
i don't know i just wasn't ready i guess
but it wasn't the food like i was
telling my wife before guys
we were in uh in a time capsule
you know on l.a we were just in the time
capsule and there was so much going on
but then again there was nothing going
on yeah
what i'm saying like there's a lot going
on i gotta go to the store we got a
podcast we're gonna get the foo fighters
this week
you know it was a lot going on but there
was nothing going on yeah and we were in
and that's as [__] up as it sounds i
don't want you to think we're whining or
anything we were having a time of our
life looking back right now
anybody who went in there you guys have
seen it when you watch the old episodes
theo doing mushrooms
acid church
[__] owen benjamin walking to toshka
hannah you know [__] it he's still
walking that [__] you know what
i'm saying
we didn't have an idea we didn't know
what we were doing but for you people
were at home watching yeah it was a
party but it weighed a lot you know he
wasn't sleeping
i wasn't sleeping you know
i remember waking up in the mornings and
going to piss and my dick in my hand
just
and to you guys it was a different i
wasn't being a hypocrite
i was just doing my job
for you guys i was having a great time
but i still remember in the mornings
waking up going
i can't believe i got two spots at the
store tonight
like i can't [__] believe i got two
spots at the store tonight like my day
is not gonna be over
until 11 o'clock at night you know
and when you're a comedian when you're a
musician when you're a singer
when you're a [__] whatever the [__]
you do whatever the [__] you do
i mean mike's a musician you know mike
if i told you
um
you were playing a gig tonight at eight
o'clock what time would you get there
four in the afternoon you know we were
talking about steve when you're a comic
you hate the daytime when you're a real
comic you [__] hate the daytime
there's nothing going on a daytime
that's got anything to do with you jobs
courts
gyms no that [__] when you're a comic
you can't wait you want to wake up at
the quarter to eight
somebody throw you in the shower and
just draw you to do because that's all
you think about all day
when i listen when i did comedy till
2007 when i woke up in the morning
this is all i had on my mind two things
what how many shows do i have tonight
and how am i gonna get a gram of coke
tonight
nothing else i didn't think about eating
i didn't think about [__] i didn't
think about sucking you think about two
things
where am i getting on stage tonight
and how am i getting the grammar blow
tonight
that's what you think of when you're in
a comic the first 10 [__] years if
you're thinking about something else
you're not doing it right if you're
thinking about your wedding or
i i can't wait to see what kim
kardashian is doing no it's not gonna
work out for you if you give a [__]
about pete davidson
it's not gonna work out for you all you
gotta give a [__] about in the morning
when you're doing comedy is to get on
stage am i right
well how scary is it though because like
now that i've had a day job for a while
i can't imagine like
working a full
nine ten hour day and then doing stan
like
that's
that's a lot and and it's also like how
do you like what because you eventually
have to make the switch to not doing a
day job but
if you're not making that much money oh
it's terrible oh my god and plus i had
to work
like minimum wage day jobs because they
were flexible in case joey said you want
to come out on the road with me in case
paulie said i have two weeks we're going
to go on a tour of the midwest for two
weeks you can't have a job like yours
with real responsibilities are they
actually flexible or do you just like
have to get new jobs all the time
because like you're like i'm just going
to quit this you know the nice the nice
lady at the gym remember the hollywood
gym where i worked she always kept the
job for me oh that was nice at the pizza
places that i worked at my buddy
yeah
that's they were like this is why you're
here go do it yeah so i worked at pizza
places
gyms and then telemarketing but it's
exhausting because you would have to
work two different jobs you're not
making overtime anywhere you're not
getting any benefits and then you're
getting up on stage at 10 o'clock at
night with
either working comics that had been
sleeping all day or like rich i didn't
realize how many people in l.a were just
rich kids that didn't have to work
that's all they did was just like you
know
an open mic
that was their job they'd work three
minutes a day
and then i was it was exhausting you
know when i got into comedy i worked the
first like three years
i was paying attorney fees and rent and
all that [__]
but by like 95 i'm like [__] work
[__] my credit rating
[__] all you [__]
you know for you because all your life
you're gonna be worrying about listen
when you get into comedy you're a
[__] nomad when you get into music
you're a [__] nomad okay you know
when you become a librarian there's a
lot of [__] librarians but when you
become a comic you might be the only
comic in your [__] neighborhood or
your [__] state or whatever yeah
so like by the fourth year all my focus
was on stand-up why are you going to get
a job
what are you going to get a job will
somebody come up to you what's this
today's special
the laugh factory
what
that's what happens when you have a day
job and you're a comedian or you're a
musician and you got a gig that night
that's all you're looking for if i would
have had a family
i would have had to have a day job go
home put the kids to sleep whatever help
my wife or whatever the [__] i had to do
and then hopefully somebody's got a spot
for you at nine o'clock yeah it's a
great life i mean if you make
60 000 a year in your day job whatever
selling insurance an office job an
economist
you could still put together another 10
gs a year at night working comedy oh yes
you could do the weekends i worked with
a couple guys that were [__]
hilarious in denver
one black guy particularly i forget what
his name was i loved him he was a
[__] attorney wow so at night he
would have and you want let me tell you
what his joke was my favorite joke he
had he was a black dude really handsome
dude
cool i forget what his name is god
forgive me
but he would have his closer or his you
guys like the godfather and people go
yeah we like the godfather he goes
this is my impersonation
of vito corleone and he would turn
around
and put the cotton balls in his mouth
and they turn back around and go
somebody [__] up my teeth that was an
impersonation
and you know i used to love that goofy
[__] i love silly
and it got funnier the more you saw you
probably saw that
he would do that [__] like somebody
[__] up my feet
that's awesome he would have the cotton
balls on the side and [__] [__]
tremendous but that guy made great money
i still remember doing wyoming with him
like a fry like he picked me up like a
six we got to do like 100 miles an hour
to get to the gig by eight you know he
had a suit on
and he was telling me because i worked
like two weekends local you know like
that
in colorado back then yeah you have your
comedy clubs but you also have like uh
the poconos with duke comedy on fridays
and saturdays yep
they know you know that you
you know they hire local guys yep i was
telling you that there's a restaurant in
manalapan maybe i think on the 79 stacks
[__] tremendous breakfast if you get
a minute to go to stacks
get the [__] uh pro dish oh my god
it's a little dish they give you what do
you have like a denny's those disgusting
things grand slam grand no no the other
one that comes with the dish they put
the two eggs on top
and you're supposed to cut it up denny's
was definitely
all those places they have those
moon over my hands no you know miami is
not bad
that's my [__] moon's over miami but
they have those things where they put
potatoes
there we go dog
i'd never liked the skillet like i went
to a diner somebody referred me a dear
friend of mine referred me to a diner
they have uh
what's the little potatoes
tater tots tater tot they have a tater
tot yeah i know i know i know my
breakfast
i don't think you i don't even think you
would like it
it's only for fat people i love tater
tots what do you want let me tell you no
no no
how dare you say i don't like taste it's
tater tots with sausage peppers home
fries
topped with like six different types of
cheese yes please little bacon bits okay
ham sausage and [__] it's disgusting
and then they put two eggs on top of
that
covered with [__] cheese i mean
too much it's too much fun
i don't like in fact i ate it one time
and i was supposed to drive mercy to the
wreck or something i go mercy we got to
stop at home she's like why i tell you
when we get a dog i destroyed that
little [__] bathroom ink was coming
out of it the whole [__] baby
but
stacks has a [__] pro dish it's
called like protein plate a pro
it's filet mignon chunks
with potatoes green peppers red peppers
and they give you the eggs eggs on the
side with two pieces of wheat toast oh
that sounds fun
stop it but my point is they do comedy
there
sorry about that might forget about that
they do
comedy and those are the places you do
like for me if i ever got into it if i
had a weird bug up my ass
i would start with just jersey
there's six comedy clubs in jersey
that's i could do that's 12 weekends a
year yeah
at six count you do february march april
then see you i'll see you in november
you do november december and you're done
for the year
that's it that's what i would do i would
just do local things and because i'm not
getting on a [__] plane
every week
i get caught sick guys
and my car sickness is 50 50.
so i what if i drive somewhere and i get
sick i can't go on stage i can't go on
stage it happens to me once a [__]
week
motion sickness patches do they work
it's something i'm doing something i
think it's my vision
and night
i think it's my vision at night and
every week i tell my wife we got to go
to costco this week but it's like
everything else everything else is on
the back burner
i'm having a hard time driving that
night
it sucks now like it sucks i hate
driving at night do you yeah though like
i never know who like that was the worst
part about driving after an edible in
l.a
because the the headlights and all i
don't know what lane they're in
i'd be terrified to merge i would just
stay in the one one lane because i was
like i'm gonna kill myself i have to
stay in the right lane and get off and
i so i can't jesus christ
remember the schools we don't have to
spray no more now oh thank god
and i got the garlic i ate the garlic
pills this morning so they're processing
right now in the stomach the garlic
pills will be ready we'll be fine
getting you in the corner i got to
figure out a corner
get you in there
like the seat is disintegrating when i
wiped the seat it was brown by the
aspartame
from all the farts that have gone in
dude for years we did the podcast twice
a week and you ate fish twice a week you
would have salmon and garlic pills and
come over and just
and then you and then we switched chairs
so you were right next to me so i
couldn't move at least when you're on
the on the end i could like kind of like
move away from the
get you in the corner
and honest to god how many farts have i
fought it since we started this podcast
yeah it's been tremendous my system has
changed it's the air in l.a that was
polluting no no see the thing is you've
heard ten he also has silent ones
because i would only know he farted
because he would do this he'd go
[Music]
like i learned to like okay if he starts
like shifting in his chair like i got i
have like ptsd like i have to run away i
think people are going to fart on me all
the time
oh my god you farted so much
but i have to say i that might have been
the flies
but
there were flies i still say it was
because of this the freaking
the dumpster at the office complex but
of cour of course the dumpster was your
neck [__]
my neck smelled uh probably not great
when was the last time you ate
hummus i can't
what oh yeah the birthday video
yeah there's too many calories in hummus
i like it though when was the last time
you saw a fly
when you stopped eating hummus no i was
still fat when i was there there's no
flash the flies bring hummus what else
attracts flies
[__]
right when you take a [__] and you put
it on the floor what comes to it
so if you eat hummus and flies attracted
what do you think is in that [__]
hummus [__] arab [__] like some [__]
terrorist took a [__] and grinded it
down yeah i watched a lot of those
cooking shows they put in the food
processor and they put in the [__]
hummus or some [__] maybe that's why
they're not beating bobby flynn but
that's why you don't have flies oh my
god the spirit touched me that's why you
don't have to that's why you don't have
flies anymore because you don't need
hummus anymore
the hummus has a little granulated [__]
in there i love hummus not anymore
it's so good though no it's not it
smells i saw there's a there's a kabab
place near you i saw it today where i
don't know and there's a couple
mediterranean places
i'm gonna tell you what the deal is here
okay the nine is tremendous the only
[__] restaurant on the nine that
violates the joey diaz code
is [__] there's a jersey mike's which
i haven't figured out how to light him
on fire i thought it was a jersey mike's
guy now what's what happened
it was it's cancelled once you live in
jersey right right you're allowed to go
to jersey mike
that's the plan you know many [__]
italians came over here in a bathtub to
open up a sandwich place and you're
gonna go to [__] jersey mike's to get
your [__] ham and cheese uh now i'm
your person from jersey in jersey mike
they're all from rhode island the
[__] connecticut or [__] delaware
nobody from jersey is even allowed to
work at jersey mike the food is so
[__] bad and i got to be honest
the [__] philly cheesesteak with the
works is not bad yeah adjusted to kahuna
or whatever yeah the big kahuna is not
bad i live in florida i go to jersey
martial yeah it's hard to keep track of
the rules mike like sometimes you're
like wait i thought i saw that is jersey
mike's good or bad
you can't go unless you get the
cheesecakes cannot [__] go to germany
i'll yell at you for that too why would
you want to go drink your milkshake
especially now they dip their fingers in
your pizza i'll show you a kid that does
doordash he comes over every day like i
see him
you tell me if you ever want to order
food from the outside again
did you order food from dorney
oh you dashed did you dip your fingers
in anybody's pizza and take a pepperoni
out of respect
oh i would do that to everybody's pizza
everybody's pizza i take one of those
little pepperonis off maybe a big chunk
of cheese off
oh yeah
i used to deliver chinese food and sell
coke if you don't think
when somebody would order when somebody
would order egg rolls or spare ribs i
was the happiest man on earth those
spare ribs always got that late
light i was a cheap fat guy i would i
would have counted if i was missing an
egg roll out of my order i would have
been pissed off oh i always ate
something if you ordered a shrimp dish i
took a little shrimp there's only four
now you're getting three
you know what i'm saying i don't give a
[__] so that's why i don't order food
because i know what disgusting people do
and i'm disgusting i was a disgusting
delivery driver if i liked you i didn't
do anything to your food i never pissed
in food or anything like that i just
wanted to sample it you know what i'm
saying maybe
maybe i don't want to buy a whole
[__] food you buy it and i just take
a little potato in a piece
it would be hard i was in steve's car
last night after that pizza was in it
all day after yeah tomato pie i can't
imagine being around a pizza delivery
driver or a chinese delivery driver all
night be hungry
and not
maybe have one
i get but i can't see i'm the kind of
like naive that i can't live like that
like how people like they take the top
sheet off at hotels
i can't live in it and they're like we
do that because they don't change that
sheet i can't live in a world but i
don't think they change that sheet
i have to admit i have to trust
that they're not gonna [__] you with you
that much
i can't live in a way i love you to
death
but every place i go i assume the worst
when i look at a cook i could tell that
guy picks his ass and it's my choice
to eat his food or not like when i go to
lease fried chicken right i could tell
those brothers haven't washed their
hands they got crack particles on their
fingers and [__] now i can complain but
in my world that adds to the [__]
flavor of the chicken
you know what i'm saying so i'm a
hypocritical type of dude when i come to
that [__] i go to a nice restaurant i
see a couple mexicans i know they're
catholic you know what i'm saying i know
the food's catholic i know we got a shot
you know what i'm saying we got a shot
we got a [__] shot
but there's like last time i went to a
restaurant that
listen when we go out with the parents
we can't go to a good restaurant because
we're going that dirty deep wow
so they got to push it away and move
people so we can't do that so we got to
go to a place
that takes 12 people
like last night like i said we were 30
deep it was 12 and like yeah we're like
26 deep
so we got to go to these [__]
restaurants for like
to take the reservation went to a place
last night
it was okay if i lived in california and
i lived in [__] you know
up north somewhere you know up north
there's space but now i'm watching
diners died in an automobile and they
got a ton of food in [__] bakersfield
now that i left like now i'm seeing all
these great restaurants and bakersfield
but then you have to go to bakersfield
yeah but who the [__] is going to
bakersfield not i not i
so [__] uh
you know i go to this place last night
my wife was still hot about it this
morning but again i gotta yell at her
my wife was [__] because the mojito
wasn't right and the fish and chips i go
would you order a [__] mojito from a
bunch of [__] rednecks that's what
you get this is a jack and coke type bar
or a [__] beer you ordered a mojito
look at the [__] bartenders look at
them they got [__] you know and then she
ordered the fish and chips
they burnt the fish to the [__] crisp
so when i went in there lady goes listen
we're running behind tonight we're going
to be a little late so i knew i had to
jump on an appetizer
i was hungry but it was friday you can't
eat [__] meat
here's my but yesterday you should have
called me there was a dispensation
yesterday i know i didn't eat meat i
know you ate chicken over at the chinese
yeah because i i confirmed it online i'm
with my mom because it was a solemnity
no i you know what everybody makes
mistakes and they'll eat a piece of meat
i just try to since i don't give up
nothing for lent yeah there you go i
just try to really stick to the [__]
no meat on friday
so i said what's the safe safest [__]
appetizer around here i went with the
french onion soup that's as safe as
could be unless the cheese is bad it's
it's
brown broth some bread and a [__]
piece of cheese that's what it's like
and it's good i've been starting to eat
it since i'm back here i love my soups
on the east coast
so i [__] ate that
i mean guys there was nothing on that
dish on that menu
i was in the mood for salmon i just had
salmon wednesday
so i ordered something against my core
paella
how was it
i didn't [__] blood the next day so the
seafood was obviously good
had a couple of the mussels that
it was like three inch lobster tails
when i pulled the lobster meat out you
could see that it was black like it was
what they got it from the hackensack
river oh but i took a chance columbus
did i'm not a [__] you know what i'm
saying it was 30 dollars for that pie i
got to get mine [__]
so i [__] ate the lobsters i ate the
shrimp i ate the clams i ate a couple
mussels
and i ate a couple of the rice the rice
wasn't bad but they had a ton of chorizo
i love chorizo no i'm not that chorizo
and not the chorizo they put chorizo's
supposed to add to the texture of the
paella it's not supposed to overpower
the paella it's a seafood dish not a
[__] sausage dish okay yeah they had
29 pieces of sausage
[__] i just ate around it i
didn't get sick but everybody there like
two nights ago was like [__] the food
sucked um
you got to know what to order at these
places that's a hamburger joint that's
what that is it's a bar hamburger joint
saint peter's was on you know what i'm
saying i'm nervous about tonight we're
going to get italian because i've gone
there's two stories with him in italian
for him getting mad at what i ordered
when we came to shoot the documentary we
went to his favorite italian place and i
ordered ravioli and we're in jersey now
i could just stab you and throw you in
the weeds so you better order the right
[__] food and apparently
ravioli is not right and then no and
then we went to the north hollywood
diner once my god and i ordered
spaghetti meatballs
and you stumped and he stumped the
mexican he stopped the mexican the man
give me a meatball i don't know what to
do he [__] just took chili he just
took chili i asked him i'm not lying he
took chili and threw it on noodles and
he goes maybe
and he gave it to me i'm like lee don't
eat it it was just noodles it was chili
it was just chili like they even had a
bean in there and [__] i'm like last
time i checked [__] spaghetti don't
have beans in it all right
oh yeah the north hollywood diner it was
a diner if i could get spaghetti
meatballs no
that was they were good for breakfast oh
yeah and those two pieces of bacon you
better pray they didn't give you a ball
real quick boys meat you ever get
my wife gets it my wife gets [__]
you know oscar maya the the thick fancy
cut one yeah and every once in a while
you got boys meeting that [__]
it tastes [__] terrible real quick
before we move forward
the joint is sponsored by better help
online therapy
listen a lot of us drop anything to go
help somebody but how often do we give
ourselves
the same treatment we need to invest in
yourself
invest in yourself by exercising and
therapy better help online therapy wants
to remind you to take care of the most
important relationship you have and
that's the one you have with yourself
listen we were just talking about you
know what's been going on
i had struggled with a couple [__]
questions
i contacted betterhelp they connected me
with dana and you know what i'm doing
150 [__] percent better i talk to her
once a week and uh
it's been working out you guys are the
judge i'm doing a lot better so do
yourself a favor whether it's hitting
the gym or making time for a haircut or
whatever whatever you're doing
you are your greatest [__] asset so
invest the time and effort into yourself
all right better help is online therapy
that offers your video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't want to see anybody on
camera you don't have to i know how it
is
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you could be matched with a
therapist within 48 hours and it's a lot
cheaper right give it a try and see why
over 2 million people
have gone to better health online
therapy and today today monday the 28th
the joint is sponsored by better help so
all the listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's
betterhelp.com
diaz and now that we touch base on
therapy let's do our own therapy
abx the leader in [__]
gel caps and edibles
sponsors the podcast sponsors us we
sponsor them
so we figured it's time to go to church
there's four 200s and one one hundred
pick the 100
pick the 100 it's the lighter color one
what are you talking about
that's not even really you're just
saying oh no it's just that poor mouth
what do you mean they're all like no
they're not they're burning
trust me i i i uh
i know everything in here is gonna be
the same amount just [__]
[Music]
so it hasn't been a while
and you know what
it's monday morning you can't walk on
one leg [__] let's get this party
started right look at my eyes from last
night i ate 1200 milligrams last night
my eyes haven't been this red since 1980
when i ain't the quaaludes with didi and
i drank the poop [__] vodka look at
my [__] eyes my wife said this eye is
so red i it took 20 years to [__]
restore the veins in the eye and after
one night with abx caput you understand
me [__] look at my eyes they're still
[__] up from last night look at him oh
my god
i was like i smoked a little bongi roo
before but nothing seriously
you used to say that every like every
once a month he's like you know we're
gonna no more edibles
and then and then
three hours later
that'd be animals he'd call me like no
more edibles today
what is that we change every day this is
white truffle
the third in the series from [__]
laughing gas look how beautiful this is
that's yours
[Music]
oh
it's monday [__] the ice cream
shop white truffle
rainbow rutz and coco is waiting for you
[__]
so how's florida steve simone loving it
you like your new life in florida you
like living with mom you got your little
comedy gigs yeah it's great it's a
peaceful easy life i'm getting a little
bored right now
but overall so happy it's just easier
life's easier i moved my parents in i
got a little backyard
it's great you know like i'm going to
plant a little garden that's that's what
i want to do that's the next move that's
the guinea garden i don't know anything
about [__] plants
but i got to figure it out when are you
gonna get a pizza one a pizza i'm gonna
get the pizza over that oh yeah oh i
gotta give you a [__] pizza personal
pizza from carlos oh i can't taste these
[__] man they taste like the
oven that's why you're reminding me when
i used to be in boulder ledigio on
saturdays he used to take a stone oven
to farmers markets nice and make your
pizzas this pizza from carlos the
personal pan tastes exactly like that
tremendous
with some basil in that [__] oh
fresh basil i drank that water that
capsule hit my stomach and my intestines
blew up that castle i just came up with
a little abx [__] burp tremendous
tremendous ladies and gentlemen it's a
monday morning it's gonna be a good week
[__] april fool's on friday is it
really
april [__] fools already [__]
we've gone through the first quarter of
the year
and it just felt like i had covered
two weeks ago that's christmas right
this this [__] year is moving you
better get with it [__] who gives
a [__] about the b.a omicron we're going
to keep pushing [__] straight he
believed that every two weeks i got a
new [__] deal honk listen to this i
started [__] physical therapy
on my right knee
this was a hell of a week for me like
with that [__] so i went down there
monday
you know you gotta wear the [__] mask
i go in
i give the girl my name she goes alright
go on the back i'm sitting in the back
minding my own business
i got the mask on and this asian woman
walks up to me and she goes mr dancer
yeah
she goes i have to talk to you she was
really cute like 40.
thin tall and she's like i have to talk
to you uh we do acupuncture it's called
dry needling
when you do therapy physical therapy we
do the first two sessions for free
to see if you like and i'm like you know
i go to acupuncture but
free i'll take it yeah the [__] do i
gotta catch a breather like that that's
65 bucks for acupuncture to catch a
[__] break
she goes okay i'll come and uh talk to
you later to see if you have time today
all right don't worry and as she walked
away she goes
you look very nice today i'm like
what the [__] i didn't know what to say
you know i'm like oh okay
and then i went there friday
again i go in
i got the [__] they told me monday
when i was there i go this sucks with
this mass they go take it off
they go it's okay we don't have to wear
them it's your decision i go you [__]
serious they go yeah
take off the mask okay
i went back yesterday i won them without
a mask
so i'm sitting in the thing and the
asian chick comes up to me again how are
you mr diaz we have time today if you
want to do it i go okay yeah she goes
where's your math go listen lady it's
over
it's over lady that's it why do you have
a [__] and i started really like not
really killing her i just started like
busting the ball
and again she said to me you look kind
of nice today i'm like you look nice
yourself i don't know what the [__]
going on there
so she goes when you come back monday
come to my office instead don't come
here first come to my office let me
needle it first i'm like i told my wife
i go to my wife some lady hit on me
she's like who cares she's not gonna do
nothing anyway
my wife already knows
so what were you saying about the
[__] needling or whatever i don't
know i don't know how we got it no you
were talking about about um happy being
in florida oh yeah it's great it's great
when i moved there i didn't know how
different their cove response was from
los angeles
like i got there
and i'm like
is covet still happening like i there
was a
nobody wearing masks there was nobody
paying attention nobody paid they were
living their life they had us so scared
in california i remember when you guys
went away
didn't you like kick a woman out of an
elevator because she coughed with him
yeah when we came back from atlanta when
we came that's what i knew it was gonna
i got a funny feeling in that moment
that this is going to be serious i've
always said that that the day kobe died
yeah we were coming home that day that's
the day kobe dino we were driving on the
405 guys
there were leaves it was a great day and
there were leaves
and the leaves were just moving on the
in a way that i never saw before like
in a circle and then another time i saw
it in burbank
when i went to burbank and i saw leaves
like that i went to
the cuban place to get food takeout
right before the
we moved like in it was july so they had
loosened up restrictions
porto's wasn't even open
they had [__]
uh paper towels or something on the
windows yeah you had to meet the girl
outside and then she gave you a time
yeah you got to come back an hour later
and get the food it was a nightmare
disaster and i go [__] it i just go over
to the record store
i went to the record store the record
store was closed and i'm like [__]
i remember going back to porto's and
just getting out of the car
just to wait on the street half hour i
don't give a [__]
and i saw people jaywalking in burbank
which you never see yeah you never see
people jay walking in burbank i saw a
bunch of people jaywalking
let's just say i didn't see the kind of
people you see in burbank jay walking
it was not a good crew that i saw
jaywalking and i remember when i looked
at them the wind was blowing the same
way
and i go you know what it's time to get
out of [__] l.a and that was
that was my final decision because the
way the leaves
were blowing that day from uh on the way
back from atlanta
i still say it that was the day we went
into a
a different doom the day kobe died i
don't know what kobe had on him
i don't know if he was sat with jesus or
hung out with copernicus i don't know
what kobe had or what power he had god
rest his soul but whatever happened that
day it's [__] up but it's true it was
like a month before less than a month
i remember standing on january 26th your
front lawn on march 14th it was that
saturday
the store closed down like thursday
night yes i did a spot at the ice house
on friday the 13th i think it was or it
might have been that saturday night
whatever it was
everybody still thought it was going to
be two weeks the average the whole
narrative was two weeks two weeks and we
were on your front lawn and the sky was
it looked like the beginning of flash
gordon when ming merciless was messing
with the world it was that end of the
world apocalypse sky
and you looked at me you go steve simone
pray i do not have a good feeling about
this
and you hit it right on the nose and
then i remember july and you go you
gotta you gotta leave we're all gonna
leave no we're like
no man left behind everybody saying that
nobody's left behind because i i didn't
want to be responsible i didn't want to
be here and hear that league got hit by
a car right you're saying that rob
and then i'm like i got to go back out
there get the body you know i remember
when you saw the guy get hit in the head
with a bat or something on kawenga and
that's when you called me the lankership
you know we're leaving
done done and then i saw the
the white dude hit the black prostitute
in front of cvs cvs brought in studio
city at 10 in the morning yeah when the
[__] does that happen in studio city
never that's ten in the morning you know
dog come on i'm not trying to be racist
or cute here
listen in the studio say they had
three or four black people they owned
the barbecue place that we used to go to
yeah remember on fridays they had the
gumball and [__] like that was delicious
delicious
something
they were the brothers delicious when
that pandemic hit there was on just an
un
real amount of people that you would not
see in those neighborhoods whether they
were african-american whether they were
mexican i mean it was just crazy sherman
oaks was just uh homeless people during
the daytime was just homeless people
smoking meth in broad daylight [__]
right in the middle i feel like la gets
a bad rap
i'm very happy not to live there anymore
l.a as a if you think about it is a
great place to live
the problem is there's too many people
that's the problem i think the food's
not great there's some there's some
stuff that you can eat the beach the
weather is great it could be really
great but there's just so many people
brenner's had a great joke because
everybody's complaining about the pizza
in l.a he's like
who moves to l.a for pizza he goes
[Laughter]
for me it wasn't listen for me it wasn't
you guys know i love the comedy story
and you guys know i loved the ice house
and i loved [__] everything about it
i'm a california
i'm an everywhere guy there's really not
been anywhere i've never really liked
love colorado love cat love new
jersey i think the only thing that's the
difference between california well i
can't even say this because if you live
in san francisco and you're an architect
you don't really experience that
we were in a very weird business guys we
were in a business that i hate to tell
you this you know what you wouldn't sell
your soul for a [__] degree a lawyer
degree no you wouldn't even sell your
[__] soul to be a doctor no but you
would sell your soul
to be on a stupid tv show yeah people
are lost to walk into a club to be vip
that
it's it's so you see the women out there
that everybody wants to be
kim kardashian and you see
it's not the food it's not the beach
it's not the it's not even the money no
it's the same money that's what they
want they want fame and they'll do
anything for it and that little thing in
the back of your head
having that constantly dwarfs
what you see in your reality yeah
there's a brokenness there but i used to
pray i used to feel like noah i felt
like for the last two years i was
building an ark in like oh lord i can't
take this much you got to get me out of
here what am i doing here
because it was like i love this store
i've made amazing friends with your
friends i hope l.a comes back better
than ever i mean i don't think the best
years of my life were in los angeles but
there's a brokenness there's a darkness
in that city and i'm telling you the
last time i was in la i felt like it was
the beginning of a horror movie it just
felt like something bad was gonna happen
and i don't know that could have been in
my head because i live in the middle of
a cow pasture now where it's the bible
belt there's a church on every corner
people have guns it's
the opposite amazing warm people i love
where i live
but when i was in la it creeped me out i
remember just waking up going i have to
leave it was a saturday morning a car
flipped over on sunset on saturday
morning exploded like a movie the valet
comes around and then he goes don't send
any guests west on sunset i go you know
i was in line to get something fixed to
my room and instead i checked out i used
miles to fly out of burbank my flight
wasn't for six more hours i went
upstairs packed a bag ubered out i'm
like it's 10 o'clock i'm leaving i saw
two naked homeless dudes like whatever
drugs are in la now or out of a horror
movie they had swords one guy had a
sword the other guy to bat buck naked in
the middle of the street fighting and i
go i i felt like lot and his wife i'm
like i'm not turning around i'm getting
to the burbank airport and that's it so
i hope now when i go back it's better
and that's what i might do i might take
a connecting flight it's worth it to go
to burbank yeah i'm gonna go back in
june to see some of my old friends and
do a few open mics
i'm i'm just not it's worth because and
by the way now almost all flights have
stops it's very rare i've flown a couple
times and they got rid of almost all the
flights i would flights are three times
as expensive as i do i'll fly from here
to vegas yeah and take a southwest from
smart
to [__] burbank burbank that's really
small yep that's the way to do it that
is
genius that's the way to do this fly
like delta from here to there nice and
then that
southwest that's genius for a [__]
hour and you could even land and catch
like a two hour so i could leave here at
six
land in vegas at 11 get something to eat
yeah
get my luggage and go right back
upstairs to southwest
that's not even [__]
go through security again no none of
that [__] no you have to if you get your
luggage you do oh yeah i'm not gonna fly
yeah
from here to the southwest of vegas
that's not what i want no my ass no i'm
60. my [__] will blow up now that
little chair and [__] peanuts and if
there's somebody with an allergy i don't
get my peanut i'll stab a [__]
you know what i'm saying
not now not not no no not southwest you
gotta
you gotta in the southwest look at their
fears
they're not [__] around now you know
every week south fest has a forty nine
dollar sale i swear to my mother yeah
anywhere though yeah thirty years i've
never got a forty nine dollar fare they
advertise 69 go anywhere go ahead fi i
did it
strong that's like the d group
yeah if you're fights out with your abc
group if you're a c you're a [__]
mutt just hang yourself
if you're a d you're [__]
those poor people oh my god those poor
people get like a southwest ticket and
don't know they have to check in oh yeah
and then get to the airport and you see
them get like c-59
and they're waiting and they're waiting
then they get on the plane and all
they're looking at is middle seats
it's a [__] nightmare you and you
have a middle seat but you're like doing
everything you can so they're not to sit
next to you i got the knife out i'm
shaving and [__]
you had a rule we would fly uh southwest
from burbank to vegas when we go to
vegas
and we'd get on in the back and you
would take the aisle out and i would sit
the window and you'd be like look fat
it looked big so no listen in the middle
seatbelts in the middle see nobody wanna
sit next to fat sweaty guys and when
they come off you go man i just had some
taco bell
don't [__] won't get on the plane
they'll go [__] take the next flight
there's two little chubby dudes back
there reeking of taco bell with a weird
look on their face lee you've had a
weird look on your face since you ate
that edible last night what's going on
with you oh you think so this is all new
to you now again yeah you got out of
shape remember i always talked about in
training
got to be ready in the training he got
out of training
now he's going up there
with the new edition
of abx you know what i'm saying there's
no more mistakes for training
jesus look at this chunk right here
if you could figure out how many [__]
pieces are here i'll give you this whole
thing
can you imagine this
weird carnival game guess how many jelly
beans are on the jar right here it's a
hundred bucks to guess so just a
milligram
oh my god look at this that's how to
live [__]
that's a bag
it's monday you [__] you didn't
think i was showing up with the three
amigos if we can you imagine just
putting this in your freezer bet and it
smells right through the back you can
smell this [__] to the back we
got the white truffle we got more white
truffle
it's that type of [__] party we're
gonna go eat tonight
i'm excited lee's gonna be [__] pale
oh i'm so excited
i'm gonna go to a couple different
places we don't know where the [__]
we're gonna go yet but it's gonna be
[__] tremendous man i'm happy you
guys took the time to come down thank
you very much and visit you know it's uh
i got a message yesterday that
they were looking at a reddit thing and
they were talking about me doing heroin
like you know and the guy's like what is
going on with people you know like
that they could have sworn we run the
church we did heroin or something anyway
and i said you know
what's that a while ago there was
somebody had a video of you guys yeah we
were doing coke they had video the guy
was running uh the youtube site
he ran a youtube site about us
then we [__] reported him he's like
well i got look at the video of you guys
snorting coke and i'm like well i call
lee
they got videos of us norton coke i
guess there's two actors playing us
because
we had the [__] and we had that
dunkin dust in there
we got [__] up that day we never
stored a coke no we never started [__]
we did that other [__] and you and you
hate needles how are you gonna do heroin
i know that the blessing people are just
it's like right now we're living in a
world like yeah people just say [__] and
they wish it stays like the guy who said
uh you know
it's like the guy who said uh
uh you know [__] uh
justify the police what's that stumble
the police what was that thing
after and we did it now we're asking for
more oh
yeah somebody said defund the police
that's a great idea defund the police
everybody jumped on it it wasn't that
good of a [__] idea
it wasn't that good of a [__] idea
and now all those places that be funned
they're looking to [__] pick up extra
[__] money to get them back you know
so
whoever's talking stupidly it's like
listen we did heroin
we did coke take that look off your face
look at that knife i did
you look like i [__] farted a garlic
fart next to your [__] not yet i'm
sure it's coming
no [__] that's great no people are crazy
people questions and and it's
i you just can't you can't worry about
it
people are crazy even like in daily life
like people send people like that i had
to i got on tick tock for like a week i
wasn't making anything but i had to
delete it because it was addicting
because you would just swipe and swipe
and swipe and swipe but it
what's big on there right now is like
people fighting videos and like cameras
like people like yelling at people
like people
like yeah you can't worry
people are [__] crazy and that's why
we stay home like you were talking about
like oh being in la is great
when you're trying to be something and
do but it's also like at a certain point
you're like okay is all the other [__]
in l.a worth it correct so we'll do that
and then at some point it's not worth it
yes and so now you're like yeah i'm a
little bored but i love it i also don't
have to do a valet parking at starbucks
everything's easier yeah yeah everything
i'm not joking they have that
valentine's day
if you wanted to go to the 7-eleven
you'd have to go around the block four
times to find a place to park and i
never lived in hollywood i only lived in
the valley and i wouldn't even go to
ventura on friday and saturday because
like it's not i don't want to i just
can't
like even that uh what what was near
there
the um what was uh crave yeah in studio
city with that trader joe's parking lot
yeah that parking lot was always a
disaster
it's just
and now it's like what's worth it right
yeah like yeah like yeah i'm bored i'm
i'm bored sometimes but i get to have a
dinner with my mom every night for like
a year and a half 100 so it's like okay
like i have a life like you you said you
were at home with your parents in la now
i mean in florida yeah when you were in
la how often did you get to see them
twice a year forever three times a year
for where i am right now just filled
with gratitude yeah
yeah i'm gonna play this video for you
guys
jesus
where do you find these things
we're gonna send this to mike he's gonna
put this here this is the way we're
ending the [__] show this week this
is a rapper here this is the best rap
video ever made
and what you're about to see
is a chick that's got that thing make
that ass move he's handicapped he's got
like a [__] little crust
is he blind no he's just handicapped
but here he goes the chick is like a low
run chick look at homer here look at him
look at him oh
but the handicapped guy falls
watch
without missing a beat
[Music]
now that's the way to end the [__]
show
check this out make that ass move like
that watch the brother
with the handicap and then give it to
mike mike's gonna have to send it to
himself so we end the show with that
video
i wonder if you can put a copyright on
this youtube videos like i own that i
don't make that mess no that's a reddit
video it was voted by reddit as the best
rap video of all [__] time
make that ass move what about when he
falls and he [__]
you're gonna love it guys
another fun-filled episode of the
[__] joint on a monday you bad
[__] make that ass move
i love you [__] have a great day
stay black and we'll see you
[__] wednesday
tip top magoo
just make
[Music]
all right you [__] savages i want to
thank steve and lee
it was great to see him we're gonna go
out to get a bite to eat and smoke some
more dope if you're around we'll bump
into you but if not the joint is
sponsored by better help online therapy
a lot of us will drop anything to help
somebody out but how often will you give
yourself the same treatment listen
we invest in ourselves here i invest in
myself every day by exercising i go to
acupuncture i'm nice to cats
better how
online therapy wants to remind you to
take care of the most important
relationship you have
the one you have with yourself i love
better health it's no
drama very easy
sign up ask for my girl dana
and within weeks you'll be rolling
usually right now you can't even get
a therapist better help or have a
therapist for you within 48 hours you
understand me and it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy
and you're going to love it better help
is online therapy help his office video
phone and even light
live chat sessions now if you don't
want to be on tape you don't have to
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help
online therapy the joint is sponsored by
betterhelp
and all you savages i'm gonna get you 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
diaz again
betterhelp.com
diaz and after you get your head
together i'm gonna make you some money
this weekend with draftkings
unbelievable join the biggest college
basketball tournament of the year this
weekend with draftkings i know it's
monday but i'm trying to get you
[__] ready because i'm [__]
excited for this weekend new customers
you get five hours on a team to win and
you get 200 miles if three bets if your
team wins who's better than uncle joey
nobody if sportsbook isn't your thing
let me tell you something draftkings
pools are the best right now everyone
can play for free
all month long
with a shot to win over 250 000 in
prizes are you ready for that
all year long you're telling people how
much you know about college basketball
well put your [__] level to the test
let's win 250 000
at draftkings but it starts with you
download the draftking sportsbook app
download the draftkings fantasy app use
promo code joey but five dollars on any
college hoops team to win and get 200
and three bets if they do if they win
you win with promo code joey this week
at draftking sportsbook got to be 21
over and restrictions do apply
the joint is also brought to you by
the best you understand me
stamps.com whether you have a small
business
or a big business the time you put into
your business is a lot time is money
print official postage right from your
computer and save thousands of dollars
with stamps.com
spend less time at the post office and
more time making your customers happy
like i told you in the beginning my wife
has been with stamp.com close to 12
years now we love it it's easy
you measure the packages you wear out
the packages you print up the label you
put up the little wing on your post box
and the mailman shows up 20 minutes
later
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com sign up with promo code joey
j-o-e-y for special offer that includes
a four-week trial
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment to contracts just
go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page and then to code joey it's that
simple i want to thank better help i
want to thank draftkings and i want to
thank stamps.com but most importantly i
want to thank you [__] savages
for always having my back
stay black i love lee i love steve i
love mike and i'll see you [__]
wednesday morning tip top magoo
[Music]
you